you know there's this hurricane bearing
down on Florida so someone found this
video this is Joe Biden the last year
talking about another hurricane and what
do you need to do more than anything
else when A hurricane's coming should
you get gas should you check if your
generator is working now should you get
food oh forget about the food water
forget that there's something that is
key to the whole operation let me be
clear if you're in a state where a
hurricane is often strike like Florida
or the Gulf Coast or into Texas
a vital part of preparing for hurricane
season is to get vaccinated now
everything is more complicated if you're
not vaccinated in a hurricane or a
natural disaster hits
I think I just got brain damage while
watching that one even though I've seen
it 10 times it is I get it it's from
like a year ago from a different
hurricane but the level of stupidity
that we allowed to seep into the system
the fact that any of us pay any
attention to these people as if they're
experts or care about us or anything
else yes you better get vaccinated as
your house is being sent to oz in the
tornado you know you're hanging out with
the Tin Man and the Scarecrow who by the
way they're doing a remake of Wizard of
Oz and they're all going to be gay or
something that's that's another one
coming which I thought the Scarecrow was
gay or wasn't the Tin Man I thought they
were doing it the Tin Man in the
Scarecrow anyway
you get the point guys they lie about
everything but if you're on their side
and this is what Democrat privilege is
if you're on their side you can lie
about everything you can get everything
wrong you can you can attack your
opponent's motives and all of those
things but if you're just somewhat awake
you're going to be destroyed and
censored